i take on a much bigger level i can feel  this thing that is so big it's so much  bigger than the the human drama of a  lack of sense of beauty and lack of love  for one another is the fact that the  earth itself nature itself sees our  beauty and loves  towards us and we are deflecting that  you think it's sad not to love your  partner or spouse or child at the pure  state of beingness  it is much sadder that you cannot  receive from an entire universe that  sees you  and is sending back to you an  awe-inspired joy that you are here right  now this is definitely juliette  killing herself thinking that her lover  is dead when her lover has concocted the  perfect plan to stay asleep long enough  that there could be freedom to love we  are in our romeo and juliet moment with  universe